greetings from Atlantic City like the
dwindling number of gamblers who visit
this vulnerable seaside resort
this is a place familiar with both boom
and bust in the 1870s a combination of
sea sand and railroads turned Atlantic
City into one of the most popular
resorts on the East Coast its Golden Age
came along with prohibition in the 20s
and 30s recently glamorized on HBO's
Boardwalk Empire big hotels the
boardwalk and don't forget the Miss
America pageant showcasing beauties
since 1921
but the 50s marked the start of Atlantic
City's downward spiral cheap airfares
made places like Miami Beach a lot
closer families moved out crime and
corruption moved in and the population
plunged the Democratic Party tried to
boost the local economy by holding its
1964 convention in Atlantic City instead
all it did was spotlight the city's
decline in 76 New Jersey voters through
Atlantic City a lifeline approving
casino gambling within two years the
biggest names in gaming were setting up
shop Caesar's Bally's Harris even Donald
Trump built a casino performers like
Cher drew crowds boxer Mike Tyson had 10
fights there by the end of the 80s
Atlantic City was the single most
popular tourist destination in the
United States but the good times didn't
last casino sprung up in Pennsylvania
Delaware and Maryland and the original
Sin City Las Vegas began its own
redevelopment Vegas wanted to attract
more than just gamblers today 66 percent
of casino revenue in Las Vegas comes
from activities other than gambling
that's three times what Atlantic City
sees while just a kiss
as of next month closings fight for a
shrinking pot in what used to be called
his favorite playground